oh my god you look
so tracy
[Applause]
oh
my gosh
have you have you seen any of our um
obsession with you i absolutely have i
was right on top of all of it i was
honored and delighted it was amazing it
was just so surreal because it all
happened in december 2020 when we were
all locked in our houses and i was like
how have they seen the show how do they
know who we are it was mind-blowing oh
everybody watches this
show i mean it changed lives now i don't
want to um be um
a spoiler so if you don't want any
spoiler alerts cover your ears one two
three your character has been revealed
as none other than the one
lady whistle down it's you
okay i was screaming at the tv
of course this is like the the gossip
columnist of the town all season one
we're trying to figure out who it is
it's you i know it was crazy because
they were not sure whether they were
gonna reveal it or not it was sort of a
debate but then
what you see in season two you can see
why they revealed at the end of season
one oh that's a tea
you know you are pulling the puppet
strings to so much of the show yeah and
not until the last second 82 million
people were like
i know how did you keep the mystery
knowing i did not keep it well and said
in any way shape or form i was like i
would go to people like during lunch
break do you know who lady whistle did
this they were like no it's like it's me
so that's how i sort of tempered it
without telling the rest of the world i
was very good at just telling people on
set that it was me and it was crazy
because it's it was such a huge secret
to keep even doing press for season one
the lady whistle down i was like
oh my god what about your friends we're
like look me in the eye is it you
i did tell a lot of them and they were
so mad at me
they were like so this season i've been
not allowed to tell them anything they
don't want to know anything about it i
watched a little bit with my mom already
and they were turning around to be going
and i was like i know didn't i do good
secret keeping like i'm better at that
than you thought i would oh and
it's not like easy becoming penelope
and sometimes there's real
transformations especially in period oh
yeah and look at this time lapse yeah i
just love it my hamilton sweatshirt with
a puppy on my knee
so every day you're going through and
this takes hours right it takes about
three hours i would say yeah so it's
like a big transformation and that wig
is made you know hair by hair
like it's all really intricate all the
colors like they're matched up but
there's so much thought that goes in
didn't you have a teacher tell you that
you would never
yeah period piece yes yes yes they also
told me i didn't look irish which i
don't know what that means but because
you're irish you're like you do not like
okay i will do i wear a woolly jumper
and carry some shamrocks and then
you said to me you'll never do period
and i was like okay and at drama school
you're so you're like a little sponge
you'll take everything a teacher says
you'd be like sure sure so i would tell
people well i'll never do period drama
they see i said my face was too modern
live your life
i'd like to tell him he was wrong 82
million times thank you drew thank you
so much
yeah now
we're the casting directors and
everybody like excited about dairy girls
because everybody loves dairy girls and
was that something that they were
excited people learned
did they mention it like it was there
i'm always very fashionable in everyone
penelope it's the yellow dresses with
claire it's a lot of headbands
a lot of 90s regalia yeah we just
finished the final season of it filming
it
i know it's wild it's just it's a really
special really really special show it's
about teenage girls growing up in
northern ireland during the troubles
and yeah it's just beautiful and
heartfelt but it had you know it has an
end point and i think there's something
really special about a show that knows
when the time is to exit the stage yeah
[Music]